This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，那对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是怎么熬过那段日期的。我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在Our. My Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的心路历程，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全但极其坦诚的对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hardway。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试上造假了两次甚至更多，对吗？我造假了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格蕾丝，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I, Gem or your Unqualified Guide, talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Well, welcome to our first official episode, and I thought what better way to get started than by talking about imposter syndrome. I thought this would be a really appropriate first episode as I begin this new thing, this new podcast, just because there are heaps of unknowns, and it was a real struggle to get started because I was so nervous about
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart广播应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。哈喽，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档非常不专业的播客，由我——杰姆，也就是你们的不专业向导，和大家一起探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。那么，欢迎来到我们的第一期官方节目，我想，还有什么比聊聊“冒名顶替综合征”更好的开始方式呢？我觉得这是一个非常合适的开场话题，因为当我开始做这个新东西、这个新播客时，充满了未知数，而且由于我非常害怕
seeming like an imposter, not being good enough, not knowing enough, or not having worthwhile stuff to say. But fuck it, I did it, and as an ode to those self-doubts, why not making it? an episode about them to begin. So let's get into it. I'm sure we've all been scrolling LinkedIn at some point, like the good career-focused 20-something year olds we are, and bam, that awful feeling, the feeling of just being utterly incompetent in the things we do, our careers, our social circles, and especially in regards to our goals. Imposter syndrome, it's basically this sense that we're a phony compared to all these other super impressive people with their lives entirely in order. they definitely deserve this their success because, you know, they're worthwhile and they're very
表现得像个冒名顶替者、觉得自己不够优秀、懂得不够多，或者没有说出有价值的话，所以在开始时真的经历了一番挣扎。但去他的，我还是做了，作为对那些自我怀疑的致敬，为什么不以它们为主题做一期节目来作为开始呢？让我们深入探讨吧。我相信大家肯定都在某个时刻刷过领英，就像我们这些优秀的、注重职业发展的二十几岁年轻人一样，然后，砰，那种糟糕的感觉袭来，那种觉得自己所做的事情、职业、社交圈、尤其是目标方面完全无能的感觉。冒名顶替综合征，基本上就是这样一种感觉：与那些生活井井有条、超级令人印象深刻的人相比，我们是个冒牌货。他们绝对
impressive, but somehow we've ended up where we are just by our sheer ability to fake it, never mind any of our skills or worth ethic or abilities. So you do feel like a bit of a fraud. And I thought this would be something that we should discuss and investigate because this is a huge thing in our 20s, especially in our professional lives. We can feel incredibly insecure and underqualified for the jobs we have or the jobs we want. And when we do read, positions where we've been striving for, we've been striving for them, or we do have some level of expertise and experience to contribute to a situation, it's very easy to feel like you don't deserve the opportunities you have, especially when you may be the youngest person in the room or see other
实至名归，因为，你知道的，他们很有价值而且非常令人印象深刻，但不知怎么的，我们仅仅凭着虚张声势的能力就走到了今天，完全忽略了我们的任何技能、职业道德或能力。所以你确实会觉得自己有点像个骗子。我觉得这是我们应该讨论和研究的课题，因为这是我们二十岁时一个非常大的问题，尤其是在我们的职业生涯中。对于我们拥有的工作或想要的工作，我们会感到无比的不安全感和资历不足。当我们真正达到了我们一直努力追求的职位时，或者当我们确实拥有一定水平的专业知识和经验来为某种情况做出贡献时，你很容易觉得你不配拥有你所拥有的机会，特别是当你可能是房间里最年轻的人，或者看到其他人
people who you believe are more deserving. And what ensues can include a pretty savage pattern of self-sabotage and often attributing your success to external factors. So on this episode, we're going to talk about the origins of imposter syndrome and the psychology of imposter syndrome in our 20s. There are an abundance of links to social anxiety and perfectionism that we'll get into, but we're also going to discuss the purpose of imposter syndrome from an evolutionary perspective. I think a real perspective I have about many psychological concepts or psychological phenomenon is if it's survived, it must have a purpose in nature. But what might that be from a psychological perspective and how is imposter's
你认为他们更值得拥有这一切时。随之而来的可能是一种相当残酷的自我破坏模式，并且经常将你的成功归因于外部因素。所以在这期节目中，我们将讨论冒名顶替综合征的起源，以及我们在二十岁时冒名顶替综合征的心理学。其中有大量与社交焦虑和完美主义的联系，我们稍后会深入探讨，但我们也将从进化论的角度讨论冒名顶替综合征的目的。我认为我对许多心理学概念或心理学现象的一个真正看法是，如果它能存活下来，它在自然界中一定有它的目的。但从心理学角度来看，这可能是什么呢？冒名顶替综合征又是如何
syndrome perhaps being exacerbated by the modern day labour, cultural and social context. I think especially in this kind of information saturated and very socially dominated modern day, it's so much easier to compare yourself to others and judge your own competencies. This is particularly brutal for our minds and our psychology and has created this almost pandemic of imposter syndrome and self-doubt amongst, I'm sure, many of you as well. And the final thing I really want to talk about is that this is particularly the case for women. And all these theories emerging from social psychology really demonstrate that there are these stark differences between genders on the prevalence of imposter syndrome, particularly directed towards our professional careers. So let's get to discussing this.
被现代劳动、文化和社会背景进一步加剧的呢？我认为，特别是在这种信息饱和且社交主导的现代，将自己与他人进行比较并评判自己的能力变得容易得多。这对我们的思维和心理来说尤其残酷，并造成了几乎是流行病般的冒名顶替综合征和自我怀疑，我相信你们当中也有很多人深有同感。我真正想谈的最后一点是，这种情况对女性来说尤其明显。社会心理学中涌现的所有这些理论确实表明，在冒名顶替综合征的流行程度上，性别之间存在着鲜明的差异，特别是针对我们的职业生涯而言。让我们开始探讨这个话题吧。
So let's begin by getting some of the broad contextual knowledge out of the way, mainly just what is imposter syndrome. One of the best definitions of imposter syndrome that I can came across when researching this episode was from this author and artist. His name is Austin Klan. He's done a lot of work on imposter syndrome, particularly in the art world, and the way he put it was pretty spot on. Imposter syndrome is the psychological phenomena in which people are unable to internalize their accomplishments. That pretty much sums it up. So the term it was first used by these two psychologists, Susan Imns and Pauline Rose Clants in the 1970s and we'll go on to reference clients quite a bit. She was quite a pioneer around this concept
那么，我们先来了解一些广泛的背景知识，主要是究竟什么是冒名顶替综合征。在研究这期节目时，我遇到的关于冒名顶替综合征的最好定义之一来自一位作家兼艺术家。他的名字叫奥斯汀·克兰。他在冒名顶替综合征方面做了大量工作，尤其是在艺术界，他的表述可以说是非常贴切。冒名顶替综合征是一种心理现象，即人们无法将自己的成就内化。这基本上就概括了。这个术语最初是由两位心理学家苏珊·伊姆斯和保姆·罗斯·克兰茨在20世纪70年代提出的，我们接下来会经常提到克兰茨。她在这个概念上是一位真正的先驱，
and she kept, it was kind of her niche and she continued to do a lot of work on it into the 80s and the 90s and really kind of popularised the term. So it was first used to describe this form of self-doubt that was primarily affecting successful women which will discuss a little bit more later on. But now it's kind of evolved from its initial applications to describe these feelings of self-doubt, fear of success, fear of failure and self-sabotage. It's become more of a popular term. So I'm sure you've seen it referenced, you know, across pop culture, the internet. I saw, you know, memes about it on Instagram the other day. So it has started being applied to, you know, just more self-doubt in general rather than the specific feelings.
这可以说是她的专长，她在80年代和90年代继续对此进行了大量研究，并真正使这个术语普及开来。所以它最初是用来描述主要影响成功女性的一种自我怀疑形式，我们稍后会对此进行更多的讨论。但现在它已经从最初的应用演变而来，用来描述这些自我怀疑、对成功的恐惧、对失败的恐惧以及自我破坏的感觉。它已经成为一个更受欢迎的术语。所以确信你已经在流行文化、互联网上看到过对它的引用。我前几天在Instagram上看到过关于它的表情包。因此，它已经开始应用于更多的泛泛的自我怀疑中，而不仅仅是特定的感觉。
of fears of success and failure and of being a fraud. So although it's not an official diagnosis listed in the DSM-5, which is this big manual of all mental disorders and psychological disturbances, I think at this time psychologists and others, and even psychologists, they've really come to acknowledge it as a very real and very specific form of intellectual self-doubt. And these imposter feelings are generally accompanied by anxiety and often depression.
或者对成功和失败的恐惧以及觉得自己是个骗子。因此，尽管它不是列在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中的官方诊断，这是一本包含所有精神障碍和心理障碍的大型手册，但我认为在这个时候，心理学家和其他人，甚至心理学家，已经真正承认它是一种非常真实且非常具体的智力自我怀疑形式。这些冒名顶替者的感觉通常伴随着焦虑，也经常伴随着抑郁。
So it's not just another symptom of low confidence or excessive humility, but that's also the reason why they don't list it as a psychological disorder because many of the symptoms are actually those of other disorders. So sometimes they do just see it as perhaps almost a new manifestation of a disorder someone might already have. I actually think that it should be listed as its own disorder or perhaps as a specifier, just because it is pretty serious. So people experiencing imposter syndrome, they may firstly have a lot of functional difficulties,
所以它不仅仅是自信心低下或过度谦虚的又一个症状，这也是为什么他们没有将其列为心理障碍的原因，因为许多症状实际上是其他障碍的症状。因此，有时他们确实认为这几乎是某人可能已经患有的某种障碍的新表现。我其实认为它应该被列为它自己的独立障碍，或者作为一种修饰词，仅仅是因为它相当严重。因此，经历冒名顶替综合征的人首先可能会有很多功能性困难，
so they might underestimate their abilities, really struggle to believe in themselves, feel like they don't deserve their successes and opportunities. It's also accompanied by this deep sense that they're a fraud. And there have been some studies that have kind of suggested that it has almost a delusional basis, whereby people who have imposter feelings, they're almost a little bit delusional. They can't really confirm the reality of their success. and they can end up suffering a pretty great deal of anxiety in their professional lives. So Forbes magazine, I'm sure we've all heard of them, they've labeled it the domain of the high
所以他们可能会低估自己的能力，真的很难相信自己，觉得自己不配拥有成功和机会。它还伴随着一种深深的觉得自己是个骗子的感觉。并且有一些研究表明它几乎具有妄想的基础，即有冒名顶替感觉的人，他们几乎有点妄想。他们无法真正确认自己成功的现实，并且最终会在职业生涯中遭受相当大程度的焦虑。所以《福布斯》杂志，我相信我们都听说过，他们将其贴上了高成就者领域的标签。
achiever. Just because it's more likely to be experienced by those who have those sense of achievements or those successes that they do actually have the capacity to doubt, I kind of disagree with this. I think it's a lot more universal than we imagine, especially amongst women and people of color and some studies have even concluded that up to 70% of people will experience an instance of imposter syndrome in their lives obviously that is you know i'm sure only a couple of studies have found such a significant number but it shows that it's not exactly rare and the huge problem with imposter syndrome is that the experience of doing well as something does nothing to change your belief that you don't belong or don't deserve to be there just because of how insidious this thought
仅仅因为它更有可能被那些拥有成就感或真正有能力去怀疑的成功人士所经历，我对此有点不同意。我认为它比我们想象的要普遍得多，尤其是在女性和有色人种中，甚至有些研究得出结论，高达70%的人在生命中都会经历冒名顶替综合征的实例，当然，我知道，这肯定只有少数几项研究发现了如此显著的数字，但这表明它绝非罕见，而冒名顶替综合征的巨大问题在于，在某事上做得很好的经历，根本无法改变你认为自己不属于这里或不配呆在那里的信念，仅仅因为这种思维模式具有如此潜在的侵蚀性。
pattern is. So every time you get more success, it almost just reaffirms your ideas of being a fraud in the first place. And it makes you feel almost slightly more uncomfortable. And I came across like a bunch of interviews when I was researching this episode. Interviews with people like Serena Williams, Natalie Portman and Cheryl Sandberg, so arguably women at the very highest points in their fields and industries. And they've all admitted to this crippling imposterism. So it's almost this cognitive compulsion that even if you have every indication of legitimate success, you still have these reasons to doubt that. I don't know, this is kind of more anecdotal, but I don't really know anyone who doesn't at times feel this way, especially in an
因此，你每获得一次成功，它几乎就只会再次坚定你最初是个骗子的想法。并且让你感到稍微更加不舒服。我在研究这期节目时看到了很多采访。采访对象包括塞雷娜·威廉姆斯、娜塔莉·波特曼和谢丽尔·桑德伯格等女性，可以说她们是各自领域和行业中处于巅峰地位的女性。而她们都承认了这种令人窒息的冒名顶替感。所以这几乎是一种认知强迫，即使你有迹象表明自己取得了合法的成功，你仍然有理由去怀疑这一点。我不知道，这有点像轶事，但我真的不认识谁有时不会有这种感觉，尤其是在这样一个时代，
age where we can constantly compare ourselves with others we deem more worthy or more competent. I'm sure we've all felt that feeling before. But I think this is the thing I was discussing with my friends the other day. For someone else, you are the comparison. It's like this kind of horrendous cycle. You know, you feel really shit in comparison to someone else who has their own person, whom they compare themselves to. And I'm sure there's someone out there who's looking at you thinking you're really impressive and, you know, yeah, you're worthy of your success, but they aren't. So even though we are able to rationalize imposter syndrome and recognize our strengths and this almost universal nature of self-doubt, we really still can't escape it. And it
我们可以不断地将自己与我们认为更有价值或更有能力的人进行比较。我相信我们都曾有过那种感觉。但我觉得这就是我前几天和朋友讨论的事情。对别人来说，你就是那个被比较的对象。这就像是一种可怕的循环。你知道的，与另一个人相比，你会觉得自己真的很烂，而那个人也有他们自己的比较对象。而且我确信外面有人看着你，觉得你真的很了不起，而且，你知道的，是的，你配得上你的成功，但他们自己却不配。因此，尽管我们能够理性看待冒名顶替综合征，并认识到我们的优势以及这种近乎普遍的自我怀疑本性，我们却依然无法摆脱它。并且它
can really hold us back, especially in our 20s when we're really trying to find our place in our chosen fields and our lives in general. So let's not talk about where this feeling comes from. What are the general origins of imposter syndrome? So as this term has become more ubiquitous, so is the interest in this concept. So in particular, researchers have often really questioned its existence. As with most new concepts, there's that preliminary questioning of, is this syndrome? Is imposter syndrome real? And the short answer is, yes, it is. It definitely is. So I read this study and this kind of summary of all these studies and across 62 studies there were 20,000 participants and 14,161 of them met the inclusion criteria for imposter syndrome.
真的会阻碍我们前进，尤其是在我们二十岁时，当我们正努力在自己选择的领域以及整个人生中找到自己的位置时。所以，让我们来谈谈这种感觉从何而来。冒名顶替综合征的普遍起源是什么？随着这个术语变得越来越无处不在，对这个概念的兴趣也随之增加。特别是，研究人员经常真正质疑它的存在。就像大多数新概念一样，会有初步的质疑：这种综合征是真的吗？冒名顶替综合征是真的吗？简短的回答是，是的，它是真的。它绝对是真的。我读过这样一项研究以及对所有这些研究的总结，在62项研究中有20,000名参与者，其中14,161名符合冒名顶替综合征的纳入标准。
Just anecdotally, I felt it, I'm sure you have as well. It does. definitely seem to be these feelings that are very real and very, very impactful in our lives. So some pretty prominent theories kind of circulate the origins of imposter syndrome. My favourite's by Pauline Clance. So Clance was the woman who we talked about before who kind of discovered this kind of experience amongst high achieving women. And she proposes this cycle of behaviors and reactions that lead to imposter syndrome. And crucially, if you can kind of break the chain within this cycle or perhaps avoid progressing along these different stages. She suggests that you can actually kind of almost cure your imposter syndrome or it's kind of like
仅从经验上讲，我感受过，我相信你也是。它确实。似乎确实是这些非常真实的、对我们的生活产生非常非常大影响的感觉。因此，一些相当突出的理论流传着关于冒名顶替综合征起源的说法。我最喜欢的是保琳·克兰茨的理论。克兰茨就是我们之前谈到的那个在成就突出的女性中发现这种经历的女性。她提出了导致冒名顶替综合征的一系列行为和反应循环。至关重要的是，如果你能打破这个循环中的链条，或者也许避免在这些不同的阶段中继续发展，她认为你实际上可以治愈你的冒名顶替综合征，或者这有点像
a gateway into greater self-confidence. So this first stage is when the apostasy cycle kind of begins. It's when a person feels these initial feelings of anxiety when they're assigned a task. So this is kind of like a trigger. So, you know, this stimulus, this task that they've been asked to do or something that they need to complete. So the second stage is the need to be special or the need to be the very best. And this is really linked to perfectionism, which we'll talk about a little bit more later on. So this need to be the very best is obviously pretty anxiety-inducing. And this anxiety, it leads to extreme over-preparation. And many imposter's or people who suffer from imposter syndrome,
通往更大自信的途径。因此，这第一阶段是冒名顶替循环开始的时候。当一个人被分配任务时，会产生最初的焦虑感。这有点像一个触发因素。所以，你知道的，这种刺激，他们被要求做的事情或者他们需要完成的事情。第二阶段是渴望与众不同或渴望成为最好的需求。这与完美主义息息相关，我们稍后会做更多讨论。这种渴望成为最好的需求显然会引起相当大的焦虑。而这种焦虑会导致极端的过度准备。许多冒名顶替者或患有冒名顶替综合征的人，
they often secretly harbour the need to be, you know, deemed as the most competent compared to their peers. and like I kind of mentioned, this does create a lot of initial feelings of fear in approaching the task because your expectations are so high. The next stage is Superman or Superwoman aspects. So now that this person has committed to the idea, they're going to be the very best. They'll often overwork and overwork themselves and believe that they have some sort of superhuman ability or need to adopt some superhuman ability in order to really propel themselves. and do their very best at this. This is often met with stage four, which is a fear of failure. So they're kind of overworking themselves. They have these really just unrealistic expectations.
他们经常暗自怀有一种需求，即被认为比同龄人更有能力。就像我提到的那样，由于你的期望值太高，这在接近任务时确实会产生很多最初的恐惧感。下一个阶段是超人或女超人方面。现在，既然这个人已经坚定了要做到最好的信念，他们通常会过度工作，过度透支自己，并认为自己拥有某种超人的能力，或者需要采用某种超人的能力来真正推动自己，
And imposter anxiety is often exacerbated when you're exposed to an achievement-related task because that fear of failure is such a possibility. So it really kind of makes it very real for them in the realm, like the realm of which they're feeling insecurity. Once the task is finished, or they're near the end, there's this denial of competence and discounting praise. So this is stage five. There's a real difficulty internalizing their successes and accepting praise as valid. And crucially, this is not just a display of false modesty. Because they've set their expectations so high and they've almost convinced themselves that they need to have these superhuman abilities to achieve the goal they've set out for,
并在其中做到最好。这通常会伴随着第四阶段，即对失败的恐惧。所以他们有点在过度劳累自己。他们有着非常不切实际的期望。当你暴露于与成就相关的任务时，冒名顶替者的焦虑往往会加剧，因为对失败的恐惧是如此巨大的可能性。所以它真的让这种感觉在他们感到不安全的领域里变得非常真实。一旦任务完成，或者接近尾声时，就会出现对能力的否定和对赞美的贬低。这就是第五阶段。人们很难将自己的成功内化，也很难接受赞美是有效的。至关重要的是，这不仅仅是一种虚假谦虚的表现。
it's really hard to then take credit for it at the end because they often have this sense that oh this was something outside of me that allowed me to do this and then finally they're stage six so this is fear and guilt about success for example um if success is unusual amongst their family or their peers impostors often feel less connected and more distant and then they are kind of overwhelmed by this guilt about being different and worrying about being rejected by others which is often why we sometimes see it amongst high achievers who perhaps came from less privileged backgrounds. So there is this huge link and I've kind of mentioned it before, but one of the most prominent links and theories around imposter syndrome is this relationship between perfectionism and imposter anxiety.
因为他们把期望值定得太高，而且几乎说服了自己，认为需要拥有这些超人的能力才能实现自己设定的目标，所以最后他们很难将功劳归于自己，因为他们经常有一种感觉：哦，这是我之外的某种东西让我做成了这件事。最后是第六阶段，即对成功的恐惧和内疚。例如，嗯，如果成功在他们的家庭或同龄人中是不寻常的，冒名顶替者往往会感到更少的联系和更多的疏离感，然后他们就会被这种因与众不同而产生的内疚感所淹没，并担心被其他人拒绝，这也是为什么我们有时会在那些可能来自不太优越背景的高成就者身上看到这种情况的原因。因此，这里存在着巨大的联系，我之前也提到过，但关于冒名顶替综合征最突出的联系和理论之一，就是完美主义与冒名顶替焦虑之间的这种关系。
So if you're a self-described perfectionist, you're more likely to kind of view yourself as an imposter. And research is shown they often go hand in hand. So people who have imposterism or imposter syndrome will often report feelings of needing to be perfect. So much like impostors perfect, much like impostors in that in Clance's kind of six-stage model, perfectionists will often set these excessively high, unrealistic goals, and then experience a lot of self-deathing thoughts and behaviours when they can't reach those goals because they're so beyond their limits. So within the clinical literature on imposter phenomena and imposter syndrome, perfectionism,
如果你是一个自诩为完美主义者的人，你更有可能将自己视为一个冒名顶替者。研究表明它们往往齐头并进。患有冒名顶替倾向或冒名顶替综合征的人经常会表达出需要完美的感受。就像冒名顶替者追求完美一样，就像克兰茨的六阶段模型中的冒名顶替者一样，完美主义者经常会设定这些过高的、不切实际的目标，然后当他们无法达到这些目标时，就会经历大量的自我否定想法和行为，因为这些目标实在超出了他们的极限。所以在关于冒名顶替现象和冒名顶替综合征的临床文献中，完美主义，
it's repeatedly discussed as a dominant theme. Almost every paper you read will at least briefly mention perfectionism. So the need to be the best, the need to be able to do everything flawlessly and their tendency to overwork are the characteristics of impostors and that's also consistent with the pursuit of perfection. And the other thing that's really interesting is imposter's tendency to discount positive feedback and maintain high standards for self-evaluation. But they're also very critical of their inability to realize these standards,
它被反复讨论为一个核心主题。你阅读的几乎每篇论文都会至少简要提及完美主义。对成为最好的需求、能够完美地做所有事情的需求以及他们过度工作的倾向是冒名顶替者的特征，这也符合对完美的追求。另一件非常有趣的事情是冒名顶替者倾向于贬低积极的反馈，并为自我评估保持高标准。但他们也非常批评自己无法实现这些标准，
which could also be considered consistent with perfectionism, because perfectionists do really tend to feel self-conscious about everything they do. So this does lead to a lot of self-reflection, and for some to feelings like they are an imposter, that they're not as good as others, because they've really kind of put the microscope on themselves. And even if an individual is competent, smart and highly accomplished, having maladaptive perfectionist tendencies can contribute to this feeling, which is why it is such a dominant theme in the literature around imposter syndrome.
这也可能被视为与完美主义一致，因为完美主义者确实往往对他们所做的每一件事都感到自我意识过强。因此，这确实会导致大量的自我反思，对某些人来说，会产生一种觉得自己是个冒名顶替者、自己不如别人的感觉，因为他们真的对自己进行了显微镜般的审视。即使一个人很有能力、聪明且成就斐然，拥有适应不良的完美主义倾向也会导致这种感觉，这就是为什么它是围绕冒名顶替综合征的文献中的一个如此突出的主题。
The next kind of, I would say, theory, but it's more like a broad-based kind of idea that gets applied to a lot of different areas in psychology. It's that imposter syndrome is a result of your personality. It's a result of your disposition. So personality traits associated with neuroticism, they're more likely to predict imposter syndrome in research that has been done in recent years. So research has examined the relationship between imposter fears and the big five personality traits, which will definitely discuss in a later episode.
下一个，我想说是一个理论，但它更像是一个广泛的基础概念，被应用到心理学的许多不同领域。那就是冒名顶替综合征是你性格的结果。它是你气质的结果。与神经质相关的性格特征更有可能预示着冒名顶替综合征，这是近年来进行的研究得出的结论。因此，研究探讨了冒名顶替者的恐惧与大五人格特质之间的关系，我们肯定会在以后的节目中讨论大五人格。
And they particularly wanted to look at medical students, and they had this sample in Sweden, and they found that neuroticism was a significant predictor of imposter fears. So neuroticism is a trait that often predicts anxiety, so hence the relationship here, often predicts self-consciousness, irritability and emotional stability, which is good. So neuroticism may be a strong pre-existing trait in impostors because it refers to this predisposed trait for negative affect and for low self-esteem. So imposter feelings comprise of prominent negative effect states such as self-doubt.
他们特别想研究医学生，他们在瑞典有一个样本，发现神经质是冒名顶替恐惧的一个重要预测指标。所以神经质是一个经常预示焦虑的特征，因此这里的关系也源于此，它经常预示着自我意识、易怒和情绪稳定性，这很好。因此，神经质可能是冒名顶替者身上一个强大的预存特征，因为它指的是对消极情感和低自尊的预设倾向。所以冒名顶替的感觉包含突出的消极情感状态，如自我怀疑。
And so it kind of makes sense that these go hand in hand. And there was another study, I think it was run on Harvard students, around 200 Harvard students. And it also confirmed that self-identified impostors are higher in euroticism, showing and kind of reaffirming this really significant link. Like I said, I'm sure we'll talk about the big five personality traits. in a later episode, but many psychologists and researchers in personality psychology in particular, they do really believe that a trait like neuroticism is permanent and lifelong. It's a part of our disposition. So it can be hard to alter these pre-existing personality features, meaning many people who do
所以它们齐头并进也就说得通了。还有另一项研究，我认为是对大约200名哈佛学生进行的。它也证实了自我认同的冒名顶替者在神经质得分更高，显示并再次证实了这种非常显著的联系。就像我说的，我相信我们会在以后的节目中讨论大五人格特质，但许多心理学家和人格心理学的研究人员，他们确实相信像神经质这样的特质是永久的、终身的。它是我们气质的一部分。因此，很难改变这些预先存在的人格特征，这意味着许多
feel like impostors, they might firstly not have themselves to blame, but secondly, it's a very difficult thing to change, which is a pretty bleak conclusion for those of you out there who might have these feelings. But that's just a theory. That's just one of many. And let's consider something else that some would say we can change, but we can at least interact with, whereas our personality or our disposition seems pretty permanent. So let's talk about family and cultural context. It's not a psychological concept or a podcast on psychology, if the nature and nerds, debate isn't mentioned at least once. So here it is for this episode. So far, many of the explanations that we've been discussing about the origins of imposter syndrome, they're from the nature side.
觉得自己像个冒名顶替者的人，首先可能不是他们自己的错，但其次，这是一件很难改变的事情，对于你们当中可能有这种感觉的人来说，这是一个相当黯淡的结论。但这只是一种理论。这只是众多理论之一。让我们考虑一些其他人会说我们可以改变的事情，但我们至少可以与之互动，而我们的个性和气质似乎相当永久。所以让我们谈谈家庭和文化背景。如果没有提到至少一次先天与后天的辩论，那就不是一个心理学概念或关于心理学的播客。所以这期节目就来谈谈这个。到目前为止，我们一直在讨论的关于冒名顶替综合征起源的许多解释，都来自先天这一边。
So ideas of personality, ideas of neuroticism and perfectionism, they're all things that a lot of psychologists often assume are innate and have been with us since birth. They're very difficult to change. However, there is this component of imposter syndrome. that is related to nurture, particularly our family environment and the manner in which we are raised. And a lot of researchers have found that this has a stronger correlation with feelings of imposterism than some of those personality or disposition features. So family environment, family dynamics, parental rearing styles, they can really affect the achievement values and achievement behaviour of a child and influence how a child learns to deal
所以关于个性的观点、神经质和完美主义的观点，都是许多心理学家通常认为与生俱来且从出生起就伴随着我们的东西。它们非常难以改变。然而，冒名顶替综合征还有一个组成部分，那就是与后天环境有关，特别是我们的家庭环境和我们的抚养方式。许多研究人员发现，这与冒名顶替感的相关性比其中一些个性和气质特征更强。因此，家庭环境、家庭动力、父母的抚养方式，确实会影响孩子的成就价值观和成就行为，并影响孩子如何学习处理
with success and failure. Many young adults who do feel like imposters, they grow up in families that place a big emphasis on achievement. In particular, this one study was really discussing kids who have imposter syndrome. Often their parents will send out very mixed messages about success, so alternating between overpraise of their kids, are you amazing, you're so smart, you're so intelligent, and then criticism. And this can really include. the risk of future fraudulent feelings because you don't really have a stable basis to judge your own intelligence and competence if you've got a parent or a teaching figure who's constantly kind of hyping you up and then also tearing you down so of course you're going to feel like a fraud
成功与失败。许多确实觉得自己像个冒名顶替者的年轻人，成长于非常重视成就的家庭中。特别是一项研究深入讨论了患有冒名顶替综合征的孩子。通常他们的父母会对成功发出非常混合的信息，在过度夸奖孩子（你太棒了，你太聪明了，你太有才了）与批评之间摇摆不定。这确实可能包含。未来产生虚假感的风险，因为如果你有一个父母或老师不断地给你打气然后又打击你，你就没有真正稳定的基础来判断自己的智力和能力，所以你当然会觉得自己是个骗子
because you don't feel like your personality or all your sense of accomplishment is consistent the other thing is family messages about the importance of being naturally intelligent and I found this really, really interesting. So family, this kind of broad-based family philosophy that many have about, you know, whether natural intelligence is real can really influence the ambitions and expectations of so-called imposters from a pretty early age. Impostas, they do have this need and very strong need to please, which may cause children to alter their behaviour just in order to prevent the loss of affection from their parents. And this kind of also contemplation. into attachment style. Impostors, they do tend to conform to the standards of the family in order to
因为你觉得你的个性和你所有的成就感并不一致。另一件重要的事情是关于拥有天生聪明的家庭信息，我发现这真的非常非常有趣。所以家庭，这种广泛的家庭哲学，许多人对（你知道的）天生聪明是否真实持有这种观点，可以从很早的年龄就影响所谓冒名顶替者的雄心和期望。冒名顶替者确实有这种需求，而且是非常强烈的取悦需求，这可能会导致孩子改变他们的行为，仅仅是为了防止失去父母的喜爱。这种思考也融入了依恋风格中。冒名顶替者确实倾向于顺从家庭的标准，以便
gain positive feedback and verify their sense of self-worth. And these modified behaviours may in turn conflict with their needs and their capabilities as a child because they're kind of pursuing this more dominant need to feel like they're loved. And it can create problems within our ability to internalize our success as we become more independent, become young adults, and yeah, just active members of society. And also, if your family has emphasized natural rather than developed intelligence, it becomes a lot easier to apply that logic to your successes. Because intelligence, if it's not something you've earned, and it's a reason for your success, then your success is not something that you've earned. So that's that feelings of being, those feelings of being a fraud,
获得积极的反馈并验证他们的自我价值感。而这些修改后的行为反过来可能会与他们作为孩子的需求和能力发生冲突，因为他们正在追求这种想要被爱的更强烈的支配需求。随着我们变得更加独立、成为年轻人以及社会的积极成员，这可能会在我们内化成功的能力方面产生问题。而且，如果你的家庭强调的是天生的智力而不是后天发展的智力，那么将这种逻辑应用到你的成功中就变得容易得多。因为智力如果不是你赢得的，而是你成功的原因，那么你的成功就不是你赢得的东西。所以那种觉得自己是个骗子的感觉，
feeling like you don't deserve your success. That can really come from this almost childhood philosophy that your parents may have had. And the other thing is societal pressures. And they can really add to this problem as well. So in our society, there's this huge pressure to achieve. I'm sure we've all felt it. And there can be a lot of confusion between approval and love and worthiness. So self-worth can become contingent on achieving rather than just unconditional.
觉得自己不配拥有成功的感觉。这确实可能来自你父母可能拥有的这种几乎是童年时期的哲学。另一件事是社会压力。它们确实也会加剧这个问题。所以在我们的社会中，存在着巨大的成就压力。我相信我们都感受过。在认可、爱和价值之间可能会有很多混淆。所以自我价值可能会变得取决于成就，而不是无条件的。
But it's really interesting to kind of think about where this fits. in terms of an evolutionary perspective because a big belief, and I've said this before, I have in terms of our psychology and different mental phenomena, is that if it's survived, it must have a function, if it's still here. But I don't really see how that does relate to imposter syndrome, because surely a feature of our minds that makes us feel incompetent or insecure in comparison to people we see as competition is a pretty poor adaptive feature. You know, imagine you come across this new,
但思考这在进化论的角度下如何契合真的非常有趣，因为一个很大的信念（我以前说过），就我们的心理学和不同的心理现象而言，那就是如果它能存活下来，如果它今天还在，它就一定有某种功能。但我真的不明白这怎么能与冒名顶替综合征联系起来，因为肯定地讲，大脑中让我们与被我们视为竞争对手的人相比时感到无能或不安全感的特征，是一个相当糟糕的适应性特征。你知道的，想象一下你遇到了这个新
tribe or new group of people. And within your first encounter, you're left feeling, you know, these crippling sense of self-doubt, you sabotage your own abilities, you fear you won't, you live up to your expectations. I don't think it would be a very helpful asset. I don't really know why it would survive either, because it could probably end up, you know, minimizing your chances of survival if you doubt your ability to perform, which hence influences your ability. So surely I think we would be more genetically predisposed or evolutionary predisposed to excessive confidence instead. But then we also have species filled with narcissus, which is in itself seen as a disorder. So imposter syndrome is not a disorder, but narcissism definitely is.
部落或新群体。在你的第一次接触中，你留下的感觉是（你知道的）一种令人窒息的自我怀疑感，你破坏了自己的能力，你害怕自己不会，你达到了你的期望。我认为这不是一个非常有用的资产。我真的不知道为什么它会存活下来，因为它可能会最终（你知道的）如果你怀疑自己表现的能力，这会削弱你生存的机会，从而影响你的能力。所以毫无疑问，我们应该在基因上或进化上更倾向于过度自信才对。但我们也有充满自恋者的物种，这本身被视为一种障碍。所以冒名顶替综合征不是一种障碍，但自恋绝对是。
So there seems to be some adaptive benefit to humility and perhaps a tiny bit of self-doubt, but also adaptive benefit to confidence as well. but it's just a real wonder why it's manifested in such a deeply seated way in the minds of so many 20-year-olds at the moment you know it's very interesting to think self-doubt doesn't really seem to have a function in terms of helping us survive then how come it's become just so prevalent and widely spread let's talk about LinkedIn or social media kind of more generally which really was the inspiration for this episode. I think the sharing of huge amounts of personal information online
所以谦逊和可能一点点自我怀疑似乎有一些适应性好处，但自信也有适应性好处。但这真的是一个奇迹，为什么它在当前许多二十岁年轻人脑海中以如此根深蒂固的方式表现出来。你知道的，思考自我怀疑在帮助我们生存方面似乎没有功能，这非常有趣，那么它怎么会变得如此普遍和广泛呢？让我们来谈谈领英或更广泛的社交媒体，这实际上是这期节目灵感的来源。我认为在网上分享大量个人信息
has made it a lot easier to compare ourselves to others. So social media, including professional platforms, LinkedIn is probably the primary one, but also Facebook and Instagram, can really act as a trigger for imposter syndrome because it gives us this benchmark to compare and judge ourselves against. And it implicitly may result in a judgment
使得我们将自己与他人进行比较变得容易得多。因此，社交媒体，包括专业平台（领英可能是主要的平台，但也包括脸书和Instagram），真的可以成为冒名顶替综合征的导火索，因为它给我们提供了一个用来比较和评判自己的基准。并且它可能隐式地导致对你是否配得上你现在所处位置的评判。
of whether or not you deserve to be where you are. for example someone who's in a similar position that you are now may have done two paid internships and worked for a top firm before getting their current job whereas you've just come straight out of uni
例如，一个和你现在处于类似职位的人可能做过两份带薪实习，并在进入目前的工作之前在一家顶级公司工作过，而你刚从大学毕业。
so this does create a direct point of comparison for you to create a false idea that you've only gotten where you are not because of you deserve it but because of luck or some other factor these platforms also provide an opportunity to view people more successful than you or doing things you aspire towards, but I haven't had much success in yet.
所以这为你创造了一个直接的比较点，让你产生一种错误的观念：你走到今天这一步不是因为你配得上，而是因为运气或其他因素。这些平台还提供了机会，让你看到那些比你更成功的人，或者在做你向往的事情，但你还没有取得太大成功的人。
Which is kind of no wonder an imposter syndrome has become so prevalent with the introduction of these platforms, because we can instantly judge ourselves against others at any point, any time, any situation, you know, when you're in your bed on a Saturday night, and you probably don't need to be looking at these things that are going to make you feel bad, but this self-doubt that comes from this new normal can be fairly insidious. and I've definitely felt it. I know heaps of you have as well. So I've kind of been teasing it for a while,
这难怪随着这些平台的引入，冒名顶替综合征会变得如此普遍，因为我们可以在任何时间、任何地点、任何情况下立即对自己与他人进行评判，你知道的，当你周六晚上躺在床上时，你可能不需要看这些会让你感觉不好的东西，但这种来自新常态的自我怀疑可能是相当阴险的。我绝对感受过。我知道你们当中也有很多人感同身受。所以我已经暗示了一段时间了，
but we're going to talk about the interaction between women and imposter syndrome. So far, I think we've covered that imposter syndrome can be experienced by anyone, and particularly when you're in your younger years and your 20s. But I think this term or phrase, it's more often applied to women, and that's a huge issue I have with,
但我们要谈谈女性与冒名顶替综合征之间的相互作用。到目前为止，我认为我们已经讨论过，任何人都会经历冒名顶替综合征，尤其是在你年轻的时候和二十岁的时候。但我认为这个术语或短语更多地被应用于女性，这就是我对这个
term and something I've really tried to emphasize that this is not a female issue, it's universal, but many aspects of our patriarchal society have led women to experience self-doubt in their professional lives a lot more, which is what many people see as their criteria for imposter syndrome. It's also really important to recognize that many of the environments women enter can make it hard not to feel like we are less deserving, less respected, and therefore perhaps a little bit less worthy as well. And this is especially the case in professional workplaces, which history can kind of explain in many ways. There was an excellent article written about this recently in the Harvard Business Review. Definitely a worthwhile read. If you want to
术语的一个巨大问题，也是我真正试图强调的一点：这不是一个女性的问题，它是普遍存在的，但我们父权社会的许多方面导致女性在职业生涯中更多地经历自我怀疑，这是许多人视为她们符合冒名顶替综合征的标准。同样非常重要的是要认识到，女性进入的许多环境会让人很难不觉得我们不那么应得、不那么受尊重，因此可能也稍微不那么有价值。在专业职场中尤其如此，历史在许多方面可以解释这一点。最近《哈佛商业评论》上有一篇关于此的优秀文章。绝对值得一读。如果你想
do some more homework on this topic, it's called Stop Telling Women They Have Imposter imposter syndrome. So stop telling women they have imposter syndrome. And it is a very insightful read. And yes, those two psychologists, Pauline Clance and Suzanne Imms, they did first study imposter syndrome in women. But let's kind of ask ourselves why it was that these women with outstanding academic and professional successes, these high performing women, why was it them that believed they were intellectual frauds or impostors and not their male counterparts because when this initial study was first run there was sample from both genders and as the authors of this article that i just mentioned to explain we do often falsely equate confidence most often the type demonstrated by white male
在这个主题上做更多功课，它叫做《别再告诉女性她们有冒名顶替综合征了》。所以别再告诉女性她们有冒名顶替综合征。这是一篇非常有见地的读物。是的，那两位心理学家，保琳·克兰茨和苏珊·伊姆斯，确实首先在女性身上研究了冒名顶替综合征。但让我们扪心自问，为什么那些在学术和职业上取得杰出成就的女性，这些表现优异的女性，为什么是她们相信自己是知识上的骗子或冒名顶替者，而不是她们的男性同行呢，因为当这项最初的研究首次进行时，它的样本来自两个性别，正如我刚提到的这篇文章的作者所解释的那样，我们确实经常错误地把自信等同起来，最常见的是白人男性所表现出的那种自信
leaders with competence and leadership so employees who can't or perhaps won't conform to these male-biased social styles are told that they have imposter syndrome because they're not willing to be these excessively and aggressively confident people in the workplace. And that kind of made to feel bad about that. And that then leads to this sense of self-doubt that they maybe don't really deserve to be there. And I think also it's important to realize up until about 80 years ago, professional environments were pretty hostile to the idea of including women in a high-up,
具备能力和领导力的领导者，因此那些不能或可能不愿顺从这些带有男性偏见的社会风格的员工会被告知他们患有冒名顶替综合征，因为他们不愿意成为职场中那些过度且极度自信的人。然后他们会因此感到糟糕。这随后导致了一种自我怀疑感，觉得他们可能真的不配呆在那里。我也认为，重要的一点是要认识到，直到大约80年前，专业环境对于在高级职位中接纳女性的观点是非常敌视的，
or in an advanced way. Some would argue that in some industries this is still the case. I'm sure we can all think of a few. Therefore, if you're a woman entering an environment where you automatically feel as if you don't belong, it's understandable that you begin to doubt your own worthiness. And the impact as well of systematic racism, xenophobia and other biases,
或者以一种先进的方式。有些人会认为，在某些行业中情况依然如此。我确信我们所有人都能想到几个。因此，如果你是一个女性，进入一个让你自然而然地觉得自己不属于那里的环境，你可以理解为什么你开始怀疑自己的价值。系统性种族主义、仇外心理以及其他偏见的冲击，
they were kind of categorically absent when the concept of imposter syndrome was developed. So it wasn't really mentioned. It was kind of around second wave feminism. They really just focused on women. And yes, they did include some women of color, but it wasn't really like they were looking to identify in broader kind of groups of people.
在提出冒名顶替综合征这一概念时，它们可以说是绝对缺席的。所以它并没有真正被提及。它大约出现在第二波女性主义时期。他们真正关注的只是女性。是的，他们确实包括了一些有色人种女性，但并不是说他们试图在更广泛的人群中进行识别。
So many of the groups that were excluded from the study in large, so namely women of color and people of various income levels and different professional backgrounds, even as we know it today, imposter syndrome really does put blame on individuals without accounting for the historical and cultural context that are foundational to how it manifests in both women of colour and white women. So imposter syndrome directs our view towards fixing women at work instead of fixing the places where women work and doesn't always account for the fact that no wonder women feel like shit,
因此，大量被研究排除在外的群体，也就是有色人种女性、各种收入水平的人以及不同专业背景的人，正如我们今天所知，冒名顶替综合征确实把责任归咎于个人，而没有考虑到作为这两种有色人种女性和白人女性表现形式基础的历史和文化背景。所以，冒名顶替综合征把我们的视线引导向去修复职场中的女性，而不是修复女性工作的场所，并且它并不总是考虑到难怪女性感觉糟糕透顶，
no wonder we get accused of imposter syndrome more. And no wonder that's even more prevalent amongst other minority groups, because of the historical basis in which we've been made to feel accepted in different environments. So it kind of brings this back to this discussion of whether imposter syndrome exists, which is where we kind of started. Or is it just a cultural construct used to shame people who are victims of their personality and upbringing or historical trauma of exclusion from certain environments? And I think regardless of your perspective, what is obvious is that these feelings of being a fraud
难怪我们更常被指责患有冒名顶替综合征。难怪这在其他少数群体中更为普遍，因为我们在不同环境中被接纳的历史基础。所以这把我们带回了关于冒名顶替综合征是否存在这一讨论，这也是我们开始的地方。或者它只是一种文化建构，用来羞辱那些成为自身性格、成长经历或因被排除在某些环境之外的历史创伤的受害者的人？我认为无论你的观点如何，显而易见的是，这种觉得自己是冒牌货的感觉
a pretty universal. And if you have experienced this type of self-doubt before, you're definitely not alone. And isn't that kind of a nice feeling? I always think that's a nice feeling, not being alone in something. And if there's another thing this episode has taught us, it's, I guess, to stop going on LinkedIn
是非常普遍的。如果你以前经历过这种自我怀疑，你绝对不是一个人。这难道不是一种很好的感觉吗？我一直认为这是一种很好的感觉，在某件事上并不孤单。如果说这集节目还教给我们了什么的话，我想就是停止刷领英（LinkedIn）
to compare ourselves. I don't know. Maybe this is just turned into an episode where I hate on LinkedIn. But you got where you are for a reason and you do deserve every opportunity that comes your way. imposter syndrome it's not your fault like it's definitely been kind of ingrained in us all comes from our families or our disposition or our personality so you can definitely kind of skirt some of the
来互相比较。我不知道。也许这变成了一集我讨厌领英的节目。但你走到今天这一步是有原因的，你确实配得上迎面而来的每一个机会。冒名顶替综合征不是你的错，它绝对已经根植于我们所有人心中，来自于我们的家庭、性格或个性，所以你绝对可以摆脱一些
blame on that one anyhow i hope you enjoyed this first structured episode next week we're going to be discussing breakups so yes um the big one we've all been there i've been there recently so I feel like we do have heaths to discuss and hopefully bring in some useful psychological theories to explain why breakups just fucking suck as much as they do. And thanks again for listening if you've made it this far. This is a work in progress and I am new to this and I'm sure I'll improve every episode. But thanks for your support thus far and if you do have any feedback, you can DM me on Instagram, 20's Psychology Podcast and we'll talk next week.
这方面的指责。总之，我希望你喜欢这第一期结构化的节目。下周我们将讨论分手，是的，嗯，这个重大话题我们都经历过，我最近也经历过，所以我觉得我们确实有很多话要讨论，并希望能引入一些有用的心理学理论来解释为什么分手就是他妈的那么糟糕。如果你坚持到了最后，再次感谢你的收听。这是一个正在进行中的项目，我对这方面还很生疏，我确信每集都会有所改进。但感谢你迄今为止的支持，如果你有任何反馈，可以在Instagram上私信我：20's Psychology Podcast，我们下周见。
so much for tuning in. I hope you guys have a great weekend and enjoy all the things this next week has to bring. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979 that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four was big to me. I'm Sam J. and I'm Alex English. Each episode
非常感谢收听。希望你们周末愉快，并享受下周带来的一切。欢迎收听 Look Back at it 播客。1979年对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是山姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集
we pick a year, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year. for black people.
我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。比如在80年代谈论马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。对黑人而言。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行真正无法在任何地方安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过这一情况的男人。
the same thing. Greg, Alessian, Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
同样的事情。格雷格、阿莱西亚、迈克尔·南奇尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子发表评论。